[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tony hawk joined us recently a legendary
skateboarder entrepreneur
he along with the great photographer
filmmaker sam jones
i have a documentary on hbo and it's
called tony hawk until the wheels fall
off it debuts today on hbo it's
available to stream on hbo max and uh we
started the interview i asked him he was
at the academy awards with sean white
and kelly slater and they were
presenting and i said on a scale of one
to ten how nervous were you at the
academy awards
i would say i was i was uh
somewhere around a seven or eight only
because
i just broke my leg uh three weeks prior
to that
and i was psyching myself to walk
without a lamp that was that was what i
was most nervous about the lines were no
problem it was more of the the physical
aspects of it and where were you seated
when the slap happened
uh i was just above the monkey mocks
like in the in not nosebleeds but right
in the first row of regular seats
kelly said he heard the slap
yeah it was pretty i mean
when you were there live you definitely
thought it was set up as he approached
the stage and then very quickly realized
that it was not set up especially with
the tone and his voice and
um
it was just shocking it was shocking i
mean everyone was just
what do we do what goes on here
it's unprecedented and then what happens
during the commercial break what happens
um everyone just kind of staring at each
other
i wasn't near the commotion
um but you could tell that there was a
lot of people trying to figure out
process it or or give support i don't
know it was just so it was so out there
um and
nothing that i'd ever seen at an event
live or otherwise so it was you know it
was i'm just thankful that we presented
our award before that happened
who's the baddest guy out of you kelly
and uh sean
like
the baddest baddest ass
the badass i feel like i feel like we
all would say each other kelly i mean
just in terms of longevity the guy just
won the pipemaster he's 50. that's the
case close it's kelly but kelly said you
because of the physicality of of what
happens and if you fall
you're falling on cement whereas sean
would be falling on snow and then kelly
says you know i have water
it's all relative i mean my attitude is
yes i will ride a 20-foot ramp but if i
fall on that ramp it doesn't come
crashing down on top of me
i know how to fall and survive it
but it's not going to envelop me
afterwards
and hold me down and there's no sharks
that you have to deal with yeah and you
can't drown never really worried about
that i i always thought that was just
that was too rare to me
uh
what what did you think when you first
when you had your accident a couple of
weeks ago did you know you had broken
your femur
immediately
yeah
uh
i didn't hear it but i i was sliding to
a stop and i could feel my leg sliding
way behind me
um and there was a sense of detachment
already and one of my kids was there
actually and he said i grew i
immediately grabbed it from where it was
and
and put it into place as if i fixed it
and said i broke my leg
uh call an ambulance and then and then
realized very quickly that i was stuck
in that position until the ambulance
came
which was uncomfortable were you in
shock
i wasn't in shock i i
i think i i went through a denial
immediately and then acceptance and the
and then i was so
you know it was all such high energy i
wasn't feeling the pain until i settled
down there and waited and then it was
like oh this really does hurt and
i've got a lot of i've got a long road
ahead of me immediately i just knew that
does anybody say what are you still
doing on a skateboard
um
only in the sense of what are you still
doing doing those big tricks
so
they i get a lot of support in the fact
that i still skate and they think it's
cool it's like oh that's cool you still
scared you know that but but then when
they see the level that i choose to
skate at and sort of what i was trying
to maintain that's when people start to
question like why why would you do it
what's the what is what's the end goal i
don't know this is just what i've always
done and it's what drives me
did anybody at the academy awards bring
up your acting in the movies that you've
been in
no and you know i'm insulted
okay um which
which movie which jackass movie you
think should be talked about in memoriam
you know when
50 years from now and they all tony hawk
passed um do you remember when he was in
jackass
[Laughter]
let's see that's a good question i feel
like i i had the most um
i i had the most lines and bits in the
first one okay
um so you know to see the
sort of uh range of my acting you really
can see it in the first wow wow yeah
we're talk talking to tony hawk the uh
documentary is until the wheels fall off
and one already fell off uh here in the
last couple years i felt i fell off the
wheel the wheel stayed on i fell off
but when you get to a point where you're
going to do a documentary
what do you learn about yourself through
this process
um i i guess that my my sense of
uh determination and perseverance and
the
the desire to keep challenging myself is
what has carried me through
uh you know 30 years of being a
professional skateboarder
um and
and the idea that i'm still doing it um
either is
something to be
uh praised or something
to uh be just written off of
stubbornness
what do you learn about your parents
through this documentary
or what do we learn
um that
they were very supportive in their own
way but not really present in terms of
emotionals emotionally
and
um
they did their best i mean my dad you
know he flew in world war ii and
he was in the navy and he he
he was living on a meager uh budget and
he's just trying to make it work and and
you know it just shows like
someone from his generation to be so
supportive of their kids was rare
yeah that's what i was wondering about
that
he's he's signing up he says this is
okay that it most people would say you
know that's just a hobby it's passing
but it felt like your dad was all in on
this
which given the error that he was going
up in
that maybe i wouldn't expect that
yeah you're absolutely right well i was
the youngest of four kids
and
he had a rough childhood and that he
didn't have any support from his parents
whatsoever his dad took off and and he
just had a really rough ghost so i think
he tried to overcompensate through his
kids and my brother was a surfer he used
to drive him to the beach at sunrise to
go surf my sister was in a band out of
high school he would he would load up
all their gear and so when i started
skating he saw what it brought to me and
how much drive i had
and he would
drive me to the skate park he was
actually the default he was the default
ride for all my friends to the skate
park
how cool is that
yeah amazing
you remember the first thing you bought
him
the first thing i bought him yeah
when you got paid oh
uh i think i i'd let it i i gave him a
shot it was probably a little more
self-serving but i gave him a shopping
spree at home depot
do you think he's then going to build
something for you
he did he always did the ramp
he did well the the ramp i mean the ramp
came later but the first i bought him
was just he loved like building decks
and just and and he was he was quite a
carpenter so uh to upgrade his tools was
pretty cool
how are you as a dad to your kids
uh well i'd like to think that i'm very
supportive but i also understand giving
them their sense of independence and
um identity so
they all they all skate and i and i
tried it it's hard because i'm so
excited that they all skate at the same
time i wanna i wanna step back and let
them have their
their own friends and their own
um their own crew and and their own
style of skating and so
um
i i you know i i tread lightly
uh
when we get done watching this
documentary we're gonna say what or you
hope will say what
success is a is a byproduct of
determination and hard work
and um
you know this stuff did not come easy to
me i was not naturally gifted as you'll
see very early on in the documentary and
i just put my head down and did the work
and and got hurt along the way but but
for the sake of progression um but i
think that the you know i hope the
takeaway is follow your passion it's
worth it
and a lot of times people will see
somebody do something and and think they
don't have any fear somebody plays
football oh you you don't have any fear
or
kelly slater oh you have no fear this
they would say the same thing about you
well you must not have any fear
but you do have fears it's just sure in
your sport
you're a little bit more comfortable in
what you're doing as opposed to
something else
yeah i i know so i put my ten thousand
hours in so
i think it's more that we take these
calculated risks i know what i'm capable
of i know what i'm confident with and to
some people
that it seems crazy like that some some
trick that is basic to me is something
that they aspire to do just once in
their life but i can take that piece and
and keep and build upon that um
and so i think the difference is that i
wasn't afraid to get hurt along the way
i didn't like getting hurt i don't like
trying to pretend i'm a tough guy
but when i do take my hits i get back up
and try again
well tony good luck with the documentary
and you're certainly in good hands with
sam jones the director of the
documentary a very very talented guy but
thank you and we look forward to seeing
you get back up on the uh skateboard
all right i'll get up there until the
wheels fall off
the other wheel thank you buddy
and it's tony hawk and the documentary
on hbo uh tony hawk until the wheels
fall off debuts today
on hbo